ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY TODAY'S
THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WE HAVE
TO BILLS TO HEAR TODAY A
COMMITTEE BILL.
AND THEN A SENATE BILL S. B..
TWO FORTY FOUR SO I'M GONNA
START BY PRESENTING THE
COMMITTEE BILL WAS REYES WOULD
YOU.
CHAIR THE MEETING FOR ME
[inaudible]
BUT I THAT IS.
WHICH IS.
ONE BOTH THE WAY FULLER HAS
HAPPENED.
THE BILL IS GOING ON NOT RIGHT.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM AT SO
WE'LL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
SENATOR LARA.
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
[inaudible]
TWO FORTY FOUR AFTER
AND BY REMOVING.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ARAB REGION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ACTIONS WHILE OUR COMMUNITY IS
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF THE
ATTACKS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THESE ASSURANCES ARE
NEEDED SUFFER SO FOLKS CAN
CONTINUE TO ACCESS OUR DRIVER'S
LICENSES AND ACCESS HEALTH AND
PUBLIC BENEFITS PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
EDU INDIAN OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
CHUNKS PART.
AND ALSO SUPPORT.
PRICING AND IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSING SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
FOUR AM.
EARLIER IN LAST YEAR WHEN THE
BILL WAS INTRODUCED WE DID HAVE
SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TOO AND CONVEY
OUR CONCERNS REGARDING THE BELT
UNFORTUNATELY THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN DO
NOT REMOVE OUR CONCERN
ESPECIALLY.
HAVING TO DO WITH GETTING A
COURT ORDER AND TO DO ARE
INVESTING INVESTIGATIONS ALSO
AND WE FEEL THAT IN THAT BILL
THAT -- DEAD
SAYING THAT SAYS URGENT HEALTH
OR SAFETY NEED OUR WE FEEL THAT
THAT IS NOT CLEAR IN THE BILL AS
TO WHAT THAT WOULD BE.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE WILL
HAVE TO CONTINUE OPPOSITION
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK.
TO WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM YET
[inaudible] SIX QUESTION
[inaudible]
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SING THEN SATURDAY MAY
CLOSE THANK HIM SHE CHAIRS WORK
BEST WHEN I BUT WHEN YOU GET
QUORUM THANK YOU WILL GET A
QUORUM WILL TAKE IT OUT
[inaudible]
THANKS.
ALRIGHT THAT WILL DO THE
JUDICIARY FAMILY LAW OMNIBUS
BILL I'M NUMBER ONE A. B..
THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT ABOUT HIS
WRATH.
THAT ARE AT THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
MONTHS.
ASSEMBLY BILL AB.
TWO THREE TWO FOUR EIGHT STONE
WHICH ELECT PERCENT THANK YOU
THIS WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN
ABOUT THIRTY FORTY MINUTES TO
PRESENT.
THIS IS THE FAMILY LAW OMNIBUS
BILL IT'S ACTUALLY A COMBINATION
OF OUR BILL AND SENATE BILL
FIFTEEN ELEVEN WHICH WE DIDN'T
HAVE TIME TO HEAR SO WE'VE
MOVED.
A LOT OF THOSE PROVISIONS INTO
THIS BILL.
COMPLICATION OF OF TIMING BUT
IT'S A FAMILY LAW ALL OF US
[inaudible]
LOT OF FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD
DOT CONTROVERSIAL ITEMS AND
HAPPY DANCE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT I BELIEVE [inaudible]
IN DRUM.
YEAH SO WE DO HAS ONLY FROM DSS
DANCER ANY QUESTION SHOULD THERE
BE SOME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND THE WITNESSES POST.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I SHOULD IT YOU DO HAVE SOME
FIRING.
COAUTHORS LISTED ON HER THAT HER
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
SERIOUSLY ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WILL MOVE IT FORWARD.
SO THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I ASK YOUR VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
AND YOUR BEST WORK.
IT'S WITH ALL YOU'RE GONNA GET.
I COULD READ THE BILL IF YOU
WOULD LINE NO I THINK.
WE CLOSE THIS.
OKAY CHRIS HOLDEN.
THERE ONE GUY GET.
RECESSION THOSE KIND OF PEOPLE
WHO THINK THAT [inaudible]
TEXAS.
REALLY MEANT SO THE CHALLENGES
THERE ARE NUMBER OF COMMITTEES
GOING ON AT THIS POINT IN TIME
SO SUSIE'S HAVE SCORE WE CAN
VOTE YOU CAN LEAVE.
I IMAGINE THE RULES CAN BE A FOR
FOR THE REST OF THE HALF HOUR
TODAY AS PEOPLE GONNA COME AND
GO.
AS I KNOW OTHERS HAVE COMMITTEES
AS WELL BUT WE JUST STEPS QUORUM
WE GET MEMBERS HERE.
THEN WE CAN.
TRY TO WRAP THINGS UP
.
WE GOT.
WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE DOWN HERE.
CUNNINGHAM CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
HERE KILEY THEIR MAIENSCHEIN
REYES.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM I'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B..
THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THERE IS A MOTION TO SECOND
THAT.
MOTION IS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
CONUR.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
RACE.
REYES TERRORIST ESTO.
OR THIS IS THE TO DEVELOP THIS
CAN HAPPEN.
REYES AYE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
I ALL RIGHT SO THAT BILLS OUT
THAT IS AB THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT
IS THE FAMILY WELL OMNIBUS BILL.
NOW S. B. TWO FORTY FOUR LARA
WHICH IS OUR ITEM NUMBER.
TWO TAKE A MOTION.
OKAY THANK YOU YOU ARE THE MOST
A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED.
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHOW.
CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
REYES AYE THE BEGINNERS.
THERE WE GO.
ALRIGHT SO.
I REMEMBER TO S. B. TWO FORTY
FOUR IS ON CALL THE OTHER ONE IS
OUT [inaudible]
FAIR.
FOR THANK YOU ENJOY --
YES THIS IS THIS WILL BE OUR
LAST MEETING AS FAR AS I NET WE
COULD TECHNICALLY HAVE ONE CALL
LATER ON TODAY OR TOMORROW
DEPENDING ON WELL CONCURRENCE
ITEMS COME OVER.
SO STAY TUNED
[inaudible]
A
SPACE.
FOR SO WE HAVE TWO ITEMS.
THE I REMEMBER ONE IS A. B.
THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT WHICH IS
OUT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN MAINE CHECK.
MAIENSCHEIN I AND THEN ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS S. B. TWO
FORTY FOURS ON COLUMN IN A LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
MAIN CHINA.
I WOULD REPLACE THE COP
.
SO WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
ONE A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT
IS OUT BUT WILL.
CALL AS A MEMBERS AT ON
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
TWO FORTY FOUR LARA IS A COLUMN
LISTA CALL.
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
THAT BILL AS ADULTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH